you had a blast i think for a lot of the
time it was just towards the end you
were just like okay i was just it was
exhausting because
it wasn't interesting work i'll come and
do anything if it's interesting right
competitive here's your coffee uh you
know here's here honey you know
michael always says what did you have to
say today oh clark how's your leg you
know whatever it was just for some
reason you know tom loves you
loves you he adore tom he wanted he just
spent the night for a couple nights here
we're talking about a new project we're
doing and
he's like i want to be a fournette and
i'm like well she's at 12. oh i have to
leave at 8 30.
and he was really bummed but he always
loved working with you he remembers a
scene he always talks about a scene
where he wasn't even supposed to tear up
or cry and he got emotional because you
made him emotional you were so engaged
and so present in the moment that it got
him emotional he felt like well that's
great
actors need to do for one another you
know you have to be in it all the time
you were you were always there i tried
to be anyway i loved working with glover
and that was so much fun when we were
working together yeah you know and we
we'd come up on the plane together and
go home usually together and
uh you know it was just it was it was a
fun time like the first few years were
really fun did you audition for it
no i i came in i thought you knew this
no i didn't know anything i i was doing
the huntress and so
i didn't know anything about it and the
huntress ended and i got this call from
my agent saying that they
wanted to replace martha kent it had
been shot
it was a woman named cynthia ryan right
wonderful actress so they sent me the
pilot i saw it
and i loved it because i'm the superman
fanatic yeah and i was i loved it and
then i was like oh my god i'm
[ __ ] because i uh i love this show and
now i have to go to vancouver for but i
never expected it to be
a hit show like that ever
and um when it was it was like oh my god
i've got to do this for six years the
people stop you in the streets ever yes
and throw their arms around me what and
say we love this show so much it's the
only show i can watch with my family my
family we're in terrible crisis about
all this other stuff but we sit down and
watch smallville together and that made
me so happy i thought then that's worth
it to me
to be to be a force for good because as
an actor you feel like oh i'm just you
know doing stuff that makes me happy and
it's vain and it's
what does it mean to people and it's
like
it means something to people